hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the eleventh leaches
titled arena now as you all know Magnus
Carlsen already won eight out of the
first ten arenas that were played the
time format of this tournament is one
minute each so it's a bullets tournament
we're not gonna be analyzing the games
we're just gonna show them and you know
if there's an interesting puzzle or two
we're gonna stop there for a few moments
also out of the first ten tournaments
Coulson won eight of them one he didn't
play and one I believe he had a bad
internet connection and then he just
dropped out in the middle of the
tournament I believe it was that one
where he was playing from a van or
something
but regardless he in this game I chose
this one I went through some fifty of
them and I decided this one I would
would fit our needs the best if he's
playing against the Rebecca Harris Oh
Grandmaster Daniel narrowed its key
United States Grandmaster and it's
really a nice game I hope you enjoy it
let's dive straight into it and I like I
mentioned in the previous video if you
haven't to do check out the animated
movie that we already mentioned where
and I myself analyzed the game between
alpha 0 and stockfish the link will be
the first thing you will see in the
description below so check that out as
well now let's go to the game cross and
opens with E 4 and we have G 6 we have
d4 Bishop to g7 I don't think this
system has a name it's sort of a more
modern defense with the g6 we have
Knight to c3 and now d6 with to e3
increasing the defense of this d4 pawn
here and also perhaps an idea will be
Queen to d2 to h6 to exchange the dark
square bishop sin the future much like
you would do in a fierce defense or
perhaps you know dragon Sicilian Knight
to f6 okay we have a ch3 taking away the
g4 Square from whites blacks Bishop and
night
nice to see six and now comes the knife
to f3 we have E 5 offering a trade in
the center but also offering a trade of
Queens which cross and accepts we have D
captures D captures and now Queen
captures on d8 Kings after sandy 8 and
now castling with temple we have castles
now Luke delivers check and
you either have to block it or the king
has to move there should be seven
blocking check while developing the
piece and now comes Bishop to c4 and
already you can see that the black did
not profit all that much by exchanging
this early in the center he has some
problems here the defending the f7 pawn
the problem is if you play something
like rook FA defending it and then
Bishop to c5
pushes it back and you win the f7 pawn
or you can block with 97 but then you
give up d5 pawn so here King te 8 I'm
pinning and also keeping an eye on the
f7 pawn crossing goes Knight to g5 with
a double attack against the f7 pawn and
now look to f8 bringing more defense
here what now bushes the c5 again
kicking this rook back we have Bishop to
h6 now offering a look for a bishop and
the night here and of course Carlsen
isn't interested in that first heat of
defense tonight with h4 and mountain
knights the e7 blocking the bishops
attack towards the rook king b1 cross a
nun pins here and now comes Bishop to c6
attacks the d4 pawn and cousin defender
we have f3 with a six and now comes
Bishop to b3 not allowing b5 to come
with an attack on the bishop and now
it's hard for black to do anything
pretty much it's hard to you you
definitely would want to play something
like Ruby d8 at least a trade of some of
the pieces but it's not possible because
of Bishop captures on f7 rook captures
and now rook captures forces the King to
capture on the 8th and now you capture
the roof with check and pick up the
bishop King e8 Knight captures here and
the white would be up a whole rook so
it's not easy for black to find a plan
especially since it's a bullet game so
nice to h5 was played allowing Carson to
capture on h7 a button gaining some
counter play so across and captures we
have Knight captures on h7 rook to h8
and now Knight back to g5 route back to
f8 defending the f7 pawn black of course
will not mind a repetition of moves here
but Carson is not interested in that
we have g4 removing the night from h5
from where it defends f6 we have Knight
to f4 and now comes knife to h7 again
King the rook rook to h8 but now as the
night from h5 no longer guards f6 Knight
can come to f6 with check we have King
to f8 and now comes g5 Bishop to g7 and
now comes Knight C to D 5 and here it's
again a very uncomfortable position for
black you don't really have all that
many options you can't you can't even
trade anything you can never capture on
f6 because this would simply attack the
pin piece that is the night on e7 so
here I shopped at first on d5 was played
Bishop captures on d5 and now c6 forcing
the bishop back with Bishop to b3 and
now black really again hard to make a
move like we said if you capture pawn
captures you are losing the night here
so you cannot do anything that way if
you try something like 96 to to attack
the bishop then simply Bishop
character's pawn captures and then rook
to d7 again
attacks the pinned piece you cannot
defend it via rook the rook to e8 as the
knight is controlling that and again in
this position if you capture again pawn
captures will attack attack the the pin
piece three times so here Nordisk after
Bishop to b3 try b6 with the idea of
Bishop captures and then at least the
knight will no longer be pinned but it
doesn't work here feel free to pause the
video White has a forced checkmate in
three it's a very nice Sunday puzzle so
you know give yourself time and figure
it out I'll give you a couple of seconds
as usual for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations it's a
wonderful check minion 3 and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is a bunch of capture Sonny 7
again it's not much of a much of a
puzzle as it starts with check but it's
it so it's what we got it was in this
position that another date ski resigns
in the game because now after King
captures on e7 you get rook to d7 check
only moves King to f8 and then follows
as the bishop still attacks the f7 pawn
rook captures on f7 and this is now
checkmate as the knight doesn't allow
the King to escape anywhere so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
like I said do check out the
with the link in the description below
really awesome animation and a lot of
work put into it and also here are the
results of this tournament as you can
see magnus carlsen won first place with
a rating performance of 3075 and only
with 54 games played unlike Andrew tank
penguin GM penguin I have been when what
I always thought it was a penguin GM but
now I see it's a penguin GIM ok
but regardless and retained in second
place with a rating performance of 2900
and 30 with 62 games played a 68 percent
win rate and in third place Grandmaster
Daniel narrowed its key here this game
played against Miami scolson
as a GM Rebecca Harris would a rating
performance of 20 853 with 64 games
played and the winning rate of 63% and
also a 6% berserk rate so there we have
it I do hope you enjoyed it and
hopefully everyone founded the very nice
check maybe in three I would like to
thank Maxine Platt Joe Morag Levkoff
chenkov Alfred Robinson and Lauren
Benedict for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video so your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content continuing the capablanca saga
and also checking up on your hashtag
suggestions thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday Sunday